[Music]
I've always been John to abandon and
forgotten places
[Music]
behind every door there's a story every
room and every object has something to
say you never know what you're going to
find or who you'll find
my name is Leslie mirror I photograph
and explore abandoned places in Ontario
Canada any time I go to an abandoned
house there's still an energy there's
still a story to be told you can feel it
from the time you step into your car in
that driveway and that's the beauty of
it the beauty is the unknown but a year
ago I was driving home had seen this
house a million times never thought to
stop just just another abandoned house
for some reason that day I did a u-turn
in the middle of the road and I got in
my car and started taking pictures of
the outside when I went inside it was
still an abandoned house to me and it
was dark there was stuff everywhere
any sign that you saw would have led you
to believe that nobody had lived there
it was an abandoned home I heard a radio
and a timid hello from the corner and
I'd met Lawrence he looked tired
he looked lonely he had a fractured hip
he was missing one eye he was in pretty
rough shape I thought here's your chance
to be there for somebody who needs it
it started with some visits getting to
know each other and now we're genuinely
friends I always have been a loner she
great in my life rep still dies it's
really hard to find somebody that you
can genuinely trust in this world
someone who's not going to judge you
he's made me realize what's really
important
he's just I really a good friend
and we are good young friends
people take pictures of what they care
about of what they're proud of what they
want to remember nobody takes a picture
of something that they want to forget so
I try to take his picture as often as
possible now
you